[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
donner plus de moyens au ministère de
l'Intérieur
15 milliards d'euros sur 50 c'est
l'augmentation des moyens qui seront
alloués au ministère de l'Intérieur
entre 2023 et 2027
réunit le premier décembre 2022 en
commission mixte paritaire député et
sénateurs sont parvenus à trouver un
compromis sur le projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur
en première lecture le Sénat avait
largement adopté ce projet de loi
estimant que le texte donne enfin au
ministère de l'Intérieur une trajectoire
budgétaire satisfaisante tout en
prévoyant des dispositifs opérationnels
matériels et humains pour lutter contre
l'insécurité et réprimer les crimes et
délits de manière plus efficace
pour autant le Sénat avait pris soin de
faire respecter les principes
constitutionnels guidant la procédure
pénale à l'initiative de la Commission
des lois cet objectif l'avait notamment
conduit à restreindre l'usage de
l'amande forfaitaire délictuelle à un
nombre limité d'infractions plutôt que
de généraliser le recours à ce mécanisme
en effet ses amendes peuvent être mises
en œuvre directement par les policiers
et gendarmes qui constatent l'infraction
elles exclut tout recours au juge et
leur paiement est un l'action publique
ainsi le Sénat a préféré poursuivre sur
la voie de leur déploiement progressif
infraction par infraction
l'Assemblée nationale tout en complétant
ponctuellement les dispositifs votés par
le Sénat s'est inscrite dans la même
voie
l'accord trouvé en commission mixte
paritaire maintient ainsi les avancées
du Sénat le président de la commission
des lois François Noel buffet et les
rapporteurs Marc Philippe daubrais et
Loïc Hervé appel néanmoins à la plus
grande vigilance dans les années à venir
pour que les orientations et la
programmation arrêtée par le projet de
loi trouve une application effective
jusqu'en 2027 les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire devront être
adoptées en séance publique au Sénat le
14 décembre prochain
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]